hey 42 here everyone knows the phrase
red sky at night shepherds delight red
sky in the morning Shepherds warning the
idea is as a red sky in the evening
heralds fine weather the next day but a
red sky in the morning is a portent of
overcast misery rainfall and all around
bad weather the phrase may be old but
it's surprisingly accurate also known as
sailor's delight or pink sky at night it
first appears in the Bible specifically
in the New Testaments book of Matthew
so the proverb is at least 2,000 years
old
Jesus is recorded as saying when it is
evening you say it will be fair weather
for the sky is red and in the morning it
will be stormy today for the sky is red
unthreatening and whilst big Jay was
using this as an analogy to explain to
his followers their inability to
interpret the signs of the times there
is actually significant merit in using
the color of the morning and evening sky
to forecast whether a red sky occurs
when high pressure traps small particles
and dust in the atmosphere this
interferes with blue light scattering it
and leaving only the red light shining
through hence the red sky as this
high-pressure is happening during the
evening towards sunset it typically
means that the next day will be warm and
pleasant I will explain why high
pressure creates warm weather soon but
for now just remember that high pressure
equals red sky equals fine weather the
reverse scenario where the sky is red in
the morning means that the high pressure
weather has already passed for the day
and the Sun is reflecting off rain
clouds which means you're probably in
for some low pressure rain and
we this adage is remarkably accurate and
it isn't the only rhyming whoever saying
we have there's clear moon frost soon
when do is on the grass rain will never
come to pass
mackerel skies and mares tails make tall
ships carry low sales rain before 7 fine
before 11 and many more
in short humans are obsessed with
inventing silly sayings to predict and
attempting rationalize to weather and
it's really no surprise the weather is
one of the most decisive forces in our
lives we eagerly anticipate summer is
one of the first things we check in the
morning
it can affect mood and rates of
depression if you're a kid at school
snow can be a lifesaver cyclones and
hurricanes can end our lives
and if you live in England anything
other than soul-destroying gray is
something akin to an act of God and the
Scottish still think the Sun is an urban
legend in fact in the past people
attributed the weather
to exactly that the acts of God or
rather God's appearing incessantly
through polytheistic and monotheistic
religions alike
humans have sought to influence the
weather by praying to for Marduk Horus
Yahweh Zeus vais Indra Rajan
Uschi talak and of us often accompanied
by complex and sometimes brutal rituals
and you probably pray to the weather
gods each day without even realizing it
many of us proclaim God I hope it
doesn't rain today or god I hope we have
a nice summer
whilst this has stepped down from
cutting someone's heart out and slapping
it on an altar to please tell och it's
in the same ballpark but hey if you
really need a sunny day tomorrow you
could always try giving that old school
option ago the age-old perception of
weather as a physical manifestation of
divine power makes sense as intelligence
as human beings are though ever in many
ways represents a god-like force and
influence over our lives of all the
natural world's phenomena the weather is
perhaps the most obvious example of
Mother Nature's or
some unbridled uncontrollable power but
before I delve into that world ending
catastrophes we all know and love I need
to explain how we actually arrived there
in the first place how exactly does a
light sprinkle become a tornado and to
do that I need to commit the worst
social sin of all time I need to talk
about the weather
firstly what is the weather well the
term weather describes the temporary
conditions of the atmosphere which is
the layer of air that surrounds the
earth composed of nitrogen oxygen water
vapor carbon dioxide farts and argon and
it makes up the air you're breathing now
the atmosphere serves as a gaseous
barrier between our planet and the
endless universe beyond our planets has
a gravitational pull is bombarded with
sunlight and intergalactic ultraviolet
radiation and has topography ranging
from oceans to enormous mountain ranges
each being an element which influences
our atmosphere it cycles of air and how
the weather behaves one of the most
crucial concepts to grasp about the
weather is that it's all interconnected
it's a single contiguous global system
what's normal for your part of the world
such as the frigid winds of Alaska is
intrinsically linked with and can affect
other weather systems all around the
globe
there's an old adage that goes something
like this if it was a fly flaps its
wings on one side of the world it can
cause it tornado on the other side it's
not actually true but the butterfly
effect as it's known is a nice
introduction to chaos theory and how
tiny variations in a large complex and
ostensibly chaotic system can sometimes
cause enormous changes elsewhere in the
system and the global weather system is
a chaotic system and that means that
seemingly insignificant factors like
temperature in Delhi reaching a degree
higher than X
did for an hour can cause it to rain in
LA the following day or it might do
absolutely nothing
thus weather has a huge amount of
inherent randomness and this is why
despite supercomputers and decades of
research we are still unable to predict
it with a high degree of accuracy by her
gunshot thud echoes far beyond this
point of origin the weather in your
region has a reach of hundreds to
thousands of miles this is why storms
that start their life hurting nobody in
the Atlantic eventually end up tearing
through the Caribbean towards Florida
likewise the region of earth you call
home has its own localized weather
patterns for example Egypt is dry and
extremely hot
where are cities like Medellin Colombia
exists in a state of near perfect
weather all year round hence the name
Lac Courte at Bella Eterna Primavera
which literally means the city of
eternal spring I guess that makes
Australia el pase della Turner cancer De
Pere or the country of eternal skin
cancer each region of earth has its own
unique climate contrary to weather which
can turn on a dime an area's climate
stays the same climate being the typical
weather conditions over a long period an
area's climate can change but it takes
hundreds to thousands of years
for example Egypt Sahara Desert is known
for being arid endless sand but
thousands of years ago it used to be
quite green rainy and home to some
impressive lakes the five main climate
types on earth are tropical dry
temperate continental polar but there
are several sub climate types within
each of these such as subarctic and
rainforest
the tilt of the planet itself is what
creates the seasons planetary tilt
increases the amount of solar radiation
countries get during certain periods of
the year because the sun's rays are
spread unevenly over the surface
depending on where they hits the earth
resulting in seasons that range from hot
summers to cold winters or if your base
near the equator hot all year round with
bounce of intense rain followed by heat
during the spring and autumn equinoxes
equinoxes being if you don't know a
period when it's light and dark in equal
measure throughout the day there are six
main components that constitute what we
laymen call the whether these are
temperature atmospheric pressure wind
humidity precipitation and cloudiness
temperature is quite simply the measure
of how hot the atmosphere is measured in
Celsius or Fahrenheit depending on how
you pronounce tomato atmospheric
pressure however is a little bit more
complicated the atmosphere is believed
to have originally escaped from the
planet itself formed in the heat of
radioactive decay and spewed out by
volcanoes which is about as awesome as
it sounds all originally filled with
poisonous on breathable air over roughly
a million years it was slowly infused
with oxygen and transmuted into the
refreshing tonic that we now enjoy
although it's worth mentioning that
global warming aside this is probably
not the final form of our planet's
atmosphere the atmosphere is held in
place by gravity even though it fins out
into nothingness 60 miles above sea
level although most of the weather you
experience such as clouds and wind are
contained within the first twenty miles
it weighs 4.99 quadrillion metric tons
which sounds like a lot and it is but
the earth itself weighs about 1 million
times that but the weight or more
accurately mass of the atmosphere is
what causes air
even though a handful of air is
virtually weightless it has overwhelming
mass when you take a huge chunk of it
and if you were to hold out your palm
you would in essence be supporting a 60
mile high column of air that stretched
out into space weighing several tons
this weight means that the majority of
the oxygen-rich air is below a free mile
altitude because air pressure pushes
down on the air below it making it
denser and thus more full of oxygen per
breath this is why when you go up a
mountain it's more difficult to breathe
less weight less pressure less oxygen
there are four layers to the planet's
atmosphere the troposphere which is
where the entire planet resides the
stratosphere which contains the ozone
layer the icy cold mesosphere and meso
pause not to be confused with the
menopause which is something quite
different the low density but searing
hot thermosphere the temperature here
reaches 2500 degrees Celsius but if you
were to hang out there you would
actually feel very very cold because
there aren't enough air particles to
transfer that heat to your body and
finally the exosphere which extends into
space these varying layers of atmosphere
are governed by the weakening gravity
and varying pressures that affects the
molecules within as temperature
increases the molecules move around more
causing torrents of vertical air
currents as the air becomes less dense
it moves into cooler regions becoming
denser and sinks back down again into
hotter regions it's an endless cycle
this is why the air feels thicker in
tropical countries and thinner near the
cooler poles convection is a fancy way
to describe all of this an area where
this happens is called a convex
cell where the movement of gas in this
case a is present these convection cells
are littered all over the planet causing
movement severe from areas of high
pressure to low pressure influenced by
the Coriolis force the Coriolis effect
is when a ball spins ie planet Earth and
all three moving Witten's in the
northern hemisphere are deflected to the
right or counterclockwise and in the
south to the left or clockwise the cause
of the Coriolis effect is because the
Earth spins faster at the equator than
at the poles so there's a natural
distortion of air currents on the
vertical axis as they Bend around the
Earth's moving surface this is a
slightly confusing concept to wrap your
head around but just remember north of
the Equator storms spin counterclockwise
and clockwise south of it humans even
have an impact on winds when Chicago was
purposely rebuilt by city planners in a
structured grid the frigid wind coming
in from Lake Michigan was forced into
narrow channels causing it's a gain in
speed and strength
hence the Windy City humidity is
something everyone who traveled to a
country near the equator has experienced
humid environments are hot muggy there
are mosquitoes everywhere it feels about
10 degrees hotter than it is and he
leaves a shower
sweaty er than when you entered no I
don't like it and I don't see why anyone
would the reason humidity is so
unbearable thick and muggy is that it
describes the amount of water vapor in
the air and the more water vapor present
the less effective your body sweat
becomes so you're unable to cool down no
matter how hard you try when the air in
a cloud has a relative humidity of a
hundred percent it can no longer hold
any water and it begins to fall to the
ground as rainfall this is part of the
hydrologic cycle where water continually
cycles from sea to the air to the land
back again cloudiness is a huge part of
this precipitation phenomenon you might
wonder why you can see clouds but not
the water vapor itself
why aren't humid countries one giant
cloud how is that possible if they're
made out of the same substance well the
air is actually full of tiny dust
particles called condensation nuclei
which come from everywhere from
volcanoes to pollution when water
condenses onto trillions of these
microscopic nuclei brought together by
cold temperatures clouds are formed
so basically clouds a dusty water
delicious but what about storm tornadoes
and hurricanes well to explain these
phenomena we first need to have a quick
chat about weather systems and look give
me a break
you clicked on this video not me it's
the weather not a breakdown of the
greatest gladiator fights in history
actually that would make a good video
watch this space
anyway weather systems simply describe
the movements of hot and cold air around
the planet these movements are splitends
at high pressure and low pressure
systems high pressure systems keep cool
dry air rotating and stop moisture from
rising into the atmosphere the result is
that they usually keep the sky nice and
clear a low pressure system on the other
hand keeps warm moist air rotating and
brings storms with it these systems pass
through the mid mid points of the planet
known as mid latitudes halfway from the
equator and one of the poles the result
is that weather in these regions is
constantly changing and can switch from
calm to psychopathically violent in
minutes so if you're ever wondering why
the weather in your part of the world
seemed to have schizophrenia consider
consulting a map storms are caused by
enormous air masses racing around the
world and smashing into one another
though weather equivalent of a barroom
some of these storms become
thunderstorms there are 2,000
thunderstorms happening at any one time
across the world and this was obviously
44 lightning strikes every single second
thunderstorms are caused when a cloud
gets too jacked up for its own good
they start the same as other clouds but
turn into tall cumulus clouds when this
cloud reaches about 40,000 feet up into
the choppers fear it gets pumped up on
raindrops and ice crystals then gets too
big and comes crashing back down
dragging all the water mass with it this
creates an incredibly strong downdraft
sending torrents of wind in all
conceivable directions as for the
thunderous crack that follows that's the
result of a flash of light and heating
the air to thirty thousand degrees
Celsius making the air expands so
rapidly it forms a shock wave that
breaks the sound barrier lightning is
formed by ice crystals high up in the
cloud colliding with each other millions
of times per second and thus creating a
static charge which eventually releases
as electricity you will always
experience the flash before the boom
because light is faster than sound so it
reaches you sooner but they actually
happen at the very same time in short
imagine a fat guy leaping into a pool
screaming cannonball and you've got a
thunderstorm in less than 1% of
thunderstorms something even more
destructive than thunder and lightning
happens a tornado forms a swirling
vortex of air or multiple suction
vortices that promise to destroy
everything
in scientists aren't exactly certain on
how tornadoes come to be but it is for
that powerful updrafts are one of the
causes what is known however is how
destructive they can be the deadliest
tornado in history was that the latter
posit a tornado which caused a death of
approximately 1,300 people on its own
in fact Bangladeshi tornados are some of
the most destructive on earth 19 of them
have killed more than a hundred people
totaling almost half of the entire
world's tornado deaths but there is one
type of storm that dwarves the power of
any tornado and that's the hurricane the
bad boy of the storm world also known as
cyclones or typhoons hurricanes are low
pressure zones that's been wildly out of
control gaining rapidly in speed uncie's
they form a huge column of swirling
death that ascends into the sky spawned
out us waves of surface winds sucked in
by the low-pressure zone on the inside
of the column of fury is a relative
patch of piece called the eye of the
hurricane or the eye of the storm this
warmer downdraft is actually quite
pleasant but the outside of it is
anything but reaching wind speeds of
over 74 miles per hour and sizes in
excess of 600 kilometers these enormous
storms are the most destructive forces
on earth sending wind it use so powerful
it's like you've just walked in front of
an 18-wheeler on the motorway these
storms leave entire towns cities and
countries ravaged by destruction kill
thousands of people and cost billions of
dollars in property damage Hurricane
Katrina
for instance cost around 125 billion US
dollars in nominal damage and caused a
death of up to 1,800 people so whilst
you may enjoy the thrills of thunder and
lightning or watch tornadoes from a safe
distance if a hurricane is on the way
get the hell out of there
unless you're in the center of course
then you can prop up a nice little of
reclining chair puts an umbrella in your
Mohito and enjoy this show but don't get
too comfortable because hurricanes move
fast but aside from death and misery the
weather also has some interesting and
bizarre optical effects for example the
sky is blue because light which contains
all wavelengths of color is scattered by
the dust and water molecules in the
atmosphere blue light traveling as a
shorter smaller wave gets scattered far
more hence blue sky later in the evening
however these beams of blue light reduce
in intensity resulting in yellow orange
and red lights across the evening sky
when the sunlight passes through
raindrops the light is bent and a
rainbow is formed which you already know
well but did you know they can even
appear at night and are quite literally
called moon bows
your struggle to see them with the naked
eye but use a camera with a long enough
exposure time and its majesty will be
revealed buts there's also halos Coronas
pas helium's crepuscular rays sir comes
anaphylaxis
Northern Lights and even their
lesser-known siblings the Southern
Lights aurora australis all illusions of
Lights created by the Sun the atmosphere
and the weather well there you go with
your shining new knowledge of complex
weather systems you can blow away your
friends as you rain down facts upon them
and you'll no doubt be met with
thunderous applause thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video then please
consider supporting me on patreon
because it really helped me to continue
to make them you can find the link in
the description also you can get your
hands on a first edition signed copy of
my new book stick a flag in it by
heading on over to unbound publishing
and pre-ordering your copy today thank
you